fast 16 Monate Krieg in der Ukraine und
auch heute wollen wir uns die
militärische Situation im Land ansehen
und wir fangen natürlich an mit der
ukrainischen Gegenoffensive die
mittlerweile seit zehn Tagen im Süden
des Landes dauert und dort auch einige
Geländegewinne bereits erzielen konnte
wir schauen uns das gleich auf der Karte
an aber zuerst schauen wir uns mal an in
was für eine unglaublich schwierige bis
fast unmögliche Lage diese gegen
Offensive die russische Artillerie
gebracht hat wir schauen uns hier ein
Video einen einer ukrainischen Drohne
die ähm südlich der Front filmt wie ein
Heimat Geschütz äh verschiedene Ziele
bekämpft und wir sehen das einfach mal
schauen dass das hier an das ist also
das erste was wir hier haben
wir haben jetzt hier eine zweite
Explosion gleich eine dritte und eine
vierte und das wahnsinnige ist dass
diese ganzen Explosion da ist die dritte
und gleich da rechts außen die vierte
jede dieser Explosion trifft ein
russisches Geschütz und zwar ein mobiles
arteriegeschützen da haben wir die
letzte
vom Typ Mister S und Mister S ist die
modernste atemrede Russland zur
Verfügung hat aus den 90er Jahren gebaut
das sind sowas vergleichbar mit der
Panzerhaubitze 2000 etwa und wir sehen
jetzt wie diese arte durch die Schütze
nacheinander in Flammen aufgehen wie
also Sie also alle explodieren und nicht
mehr zu gebrauchen sind und diese
Artilleriegeschütze machen extrem
wichtig für Russland um eben diese
Gegend Offensive aufzuhalten lediglich
eins von dem wir haben das gesehen eines
wurde um einige Meter verfehlt und geht
nicht in Flammen auf die anderen drei
sind völlig zerstört da sehen wir auch
das dritte wie gesagt es eines der
modernsten Artillerie Systeme mobile was
russland hat und was eben sehr wichtig
ist um diese Gegend Offensive
aufzuhalten denn nur mit Artillerie kann
Russland an dieser numerischen
Überlegenheit der ukrainischen Armee und
dann Panzern und dann Kettenfahrzeugen
und so weiter
entgegentreten kannst uns hier einfach
noch mal angucken das also diese müsste
es die dann hier am Brennen ist und
nicht mehr benutzt werden kann und wir
haben ein weiteres Video aus der Nacht
oder aus dem Abendbereich was
noch weitere dieser Mr s ebenfalls ganz
genau trifft auf die Meta genau und
ebenfalls zerstört dass uns wie gesagt
eine abendliche drohnenaufnahme und auch
dort sehen wir hier schon die Mister s
wie sie da stehen und sehen dann gleich
wie sie eben nacheinander getroffen
werden und das ganze hier auf der linken
Seite das erste und da dann das zweite
und wir sehen auch diese riesigen
Explosion das ist also nicht kleine
Artillerie sondern das sind diese Heimat
Raketen die eben dort ein sehr sehr
großen Schaden anrichten und wir schauen
uns das ganze mal auf der Karte an weil
ich da davon gesprochen habe dass das
Russland in eine unmögliche Situation
bringt denn die gegen Offensive die wir
uns gleich noch genauer ansehen läuft ja
hier im Süden des Landes und wenn wir
uns das angucken das Heimat geschützt
was wir eben gerade hatten das hat etwa
85 km Reichweite 80 bis 85 km Reichweite
angenommen die Ukrainer positionieren
das hier oben in willicker von wo aus
ein Teil ihrer Offensive geht dann haben
sie diese Reichweite von 85 km die geht
etwas hier das heißt alles was richtig
viel oberhalb befindet wird von der
Heimat dann auch theoretisch getroffen
und auf fünf Meter genau getroffen wir
haben es jetzt gesehen wir hatten drei
Angriff vier Angriffe total versetzt
innerhalb von Sekunden weil die ja
eingeprogrammierte Daten haben die
müssen also nicht neu ausgerichtet
werden und drei davon haben auch
funktioniert was wir gerade gesehen
haben die Explosion waren etwa hier und
hier denn die russische Artillerie
schießt nur maximal 40 km weit und das
ist ein riesiges Problem das heißt
sollten die Russen eben die Front
treffen wollen hier vorne müssen Sie
sich hier rein bewegen sie müssen also
in diese Reichweite fahren und das ist
ein riesiges Problem für die Russen denn
sie haben bisher ihre Artillerie
außerhalb dieser Reichweite gehabt also
hier zum Beispiel bei Mario Polen und
bei anderen Städten nur soviel und eben
auch ein Russland das war kein Problem
dort konnten sie nicht genau gezielt
bekämpft werden wenn sie aber jetzt hier
reinfahren um eben zu helfen dann haben
sie das riesige Problem dass dort in die
Heimat Reichweite kommt und dann einfach
nur die ja die unglaubliche Wahl haben
entweder sich zurückzuziehen und nicht
zu verteidigen oder nach vorne zu gehen
und sobald sie von Drohnen erblickt
werden eben auch ausgeschaltet zu werden
von der ukrainischen
raketenartillerie vom Typ heimers und
andere wir schauen uns noch mal die
Karte im allgemeinen an um zu verstehen
wo wir genau sind und was bisher die
Erfolge oder vielleicht noch nicht
Erfolge der ukrainischen Armee sind denn
wir haben zwei große Angriffsrichtungen
bisher gesehen eine hier bei Ulrich rief
und wir schauen uns mal das Blau hier an
das ist sehr sehr wenig dort hat die
ukrainische Armee es nicht geschafft
Dörfer zu befreien sondern sie hat ihm
bloß die Fronten ein bisschen nach
hinten verschoben hat also die erste
Linie durchbrochen aber mir auch nicht
in Hannover haben wir ein anderes Bild
dort hatten wir einige Erfolg in Erfolge
insgesamt fünf Dörfer konnten hier
genommen werden wir sehen hier auch
diese weiße Linie dass die Grenze
zwischen den Region und ähm im Westen
und so nett im Osten das heißt dort
haben wir zwei Dörfer in
Saarbrücker und drei Dörfer oder vier
Dörfer mittlerweile in Donuts die
befreit werden Stunden das also
positiv für die ukrainische Armee aber
wir sehen es ist noch extrem viel was
dort vor der Ukraine liegt denn wir
haben noch den allergrößten Teil der
hier befreit werden müsste um und wir
glauben dass es das große Ziel zum also
auch schon mehr hier im Süden
vorzudringen und eben die russische
Frauen zu spalten schauen dass da noch
mal auf der auf der gesamten Karte an um
eben diesen diesen Kai hier zu treiben
im Süden also dort dazwischen zu gehen
und zu sagen wir haben dann hier ein
isoliertes Gebiet im Südwesten und ein
weniger isoliertes Gebiet weil es ja gut
versorgt werden kann im Osten ähm der
der Front
und das zu bewerkstelligen haben wir
noch weitere ukrainische
Angriffsaktionen nämlich nicht bloß auf
die Arterie weiter hinten sondern auch
hier direkt an der Front diese kleinen
Stadt heißt
darum Lügen
eine Stadt gerade fünf Kilometer südlich
der Front und dort hat die Ukraine in
den letzten Tagen auch gezielt russische
LKW russische Verstärkung rein geschafft
wurden also die Sachen die eben nicht
Artillerie sind sondern die Infanterie
sind angegriffen und in dieser Stadt
zerstört wir sehen natürlich verstecken
sich diese Reserven dort wo es am
urbansten ist wo also die meisten Häuser
sind es gibt Krankenhäuser in der Stadt
es gibt Schulen in der Stadt und genau
dort im Zentrum verstecken sich die
Russen um eben möglichst ja nicht
getroffen zu werden oder eben zu
riskieren natürlich auch dass wenn die
Ukraine sie angreifen das ist eben dann
auch zivile Einrichtung trifft das
natürlich ein großes Ziel der Russen um
eben immer auch für die Propaganda die
Bilder zu haben von wegen der Ukraine
beschießen ja ihre eigenen Städte machen
sie natürlich nicht wir sehen ganz genau
dass es jeweils LKW sind vom Typ
oral-explosion hier die dort getroffen
wurden das also eine Stadt gerade
südlich der Freund die möchte die
Ukraine als nächstes erobern südlich von
Villa was ja eben schon gesehen hatten
und das ist das nächste Ziel der
ukrainischen Armee wie gesagt die
Offensive läuft schon 10 Tage und wir
haben seit drei Tagen etwa kein
Vorsprung mehr gesehen das heißt aktuell
ist die Ukraine eben darauf bedacht
diese reser hier reinkommen die Russland
reinbewegen muss um die Front zu
verteidigen anzugreifen und zu
dezimieren um dann wie wir glauben
erneut vorzustoßen so also die Situation
hier was die ukrainischen Angriffe
angeht und wir müssen natürlich auch
immer beide Seiten zeigen und zeigen
dass es eben nicht eine einwandstraße
ist die wir haben und wir haben diese
relativ verrückten Aufnahmen hier einer
russischen
überwachungs Drohne und die zeigen uns
hier eine Situation die auch belegt dass
die Ukraine auch immer wieder große
Verluste einstecken muss die hat
dutzende wenn ich vielleicht bis zu 50
60 Fahrzeuge bereits verloren in den
ersten zehn Tagen was jetzt strategisch
nicht eine große
Beeinträchtigung darstellt denn die hat
hunderte bekommen vom Besten also 500
denken man Panzer und schützen Panzer
alleine und weitere 500 bis 1000
gepanzerte Fahrzeuge nichtsdestotrotz es
sind einige verloren gegangen und was
wir jetzt hier sehen ist ein
T-72 Panzer der einen max pro und
amerikanisches Fahrzeug versucht
wegzuschieben was er offenbar getroffen
wurde was wäre es aber gleich sehen ist
das eine Kamikaze Drohne diesen Panzer
trifft also er schiebt das Fahrzeug
schiebt das nach hinten da oben ist das
Max pro hier ist der t72 jetzt haben wir
die Kamikaze Drohne die einschlägt und
dadurch verliert dieser t 72 völlig die
Kontrolle und wir schauen uns das ganze
mal an was jetzt passiert ist und
Aufnahmen die man ja so vielleicht nur
aus Filmen bislang kennt der verliert
also die Kontrolle und schiebt dieses
Fahrzeug nicht bloß sondern fährt oben
drauf jetzt haben meint dieses
amerikanische Fahrzeug wir sehen uns
gleich an
eine Kunden jetzt hier sehen wir hier
noch mal ganz kurz um das Festhalten
hier also der T-72 und hier dieser Max
pro der eben noch vorsichtig geschoben
wurde aufgrund dieser panischen
Situation ähm jetzt aber eben von dem
T-72 überrollt wird der genau auf diese
amerikanische in meinen drei Meter hohe
Fahrzeug komplett drauf rollt und das
eben zerstört Glück im Unglück hatte die
Besatzung gesehen jetzt ist er
mittlerweile komplett drüber Glück
Unglück hatte die Besatzung wir sehen in
den allerersten Sekunden dieser
Aufnahmen dass die Ukraine die zweite
drin sind jetzt der erste und jetzt der
zweite wegrennen und sich gerade noch zu
retten konnten im letzten Moment aus
diesem Fahrzeug das also Glück im
Unglück hier doch dieser mexpo der
eigentlicher evakuiert werden sollte von
dem T-72 ist natürlich dann nicht mehr
zu gebrauchen und wir haben dann noch
weitere Aufnahmen die noch mal zeigen da
oben also einer Max pro da dieser T-72
Union ein weiterer und das dürfen wir
auch nicht vergessen dass die Russen ja
auch gemeinsam diese Aktion einsetzen
das heißt wir haben die Überwachungszone
oben wir haben die Kamikaze drohen die
eingeschlagen ist und als drittes haben
wir jetzt wir sind gleich die Artillerie
die hier unten auch die an die
gepanzerten Fahrzeuge weiterhin angreift
das heißt die Russen sind keinesfalls
mehr los und sind keinesfalls geschlagen
sondern wir haben es weiter mit schweren
Kämpfen zu tun und großen Verlusten auf
beiden Seiten selbstverständlich der
Front
wir schauen uns als letztes die
Situation im Süden an dort haben wir
weiterhin flutgebiete wer ist das
erstmal auf der Karte an wir haben
dieses
Flutgebiet hier südlich des kachowska
Staudamms der vor glaube ich knapp drei
Wochen von den Russen gesprengt wurde
und wir haben ein sehr sehr großes
Gebiet was eben überflutet ist und das
ist zum größten teilten Süden des
ähnliches das heißt in den russisch
besetzten Gebieten und die Aufnahmen die
wir jetzt sehen sind wie ich finde
absolut schockierend aber auch absolut
ja symbolisch dafür dass die Russen eben
die Ukraine völlig egal sind die unter
ihrer Kontrolle stehen wir wissen dass
im im Norden da wo die überfluteten
Gebiete waren da wurde gab es
Evakuierung da gab es hilfskonvoice da
hat die ukrainische Regierung alles
gemacht um die Menschen zu retten und
hier im Süden offiziell Russland seit
September letzten Jahres wieder erinnern
uns fast schon wurde annektiert und
Putin hat das gefeiert in Moskau auf dem
Roten Platz dort haben wir die Situation
dass überhaupt nichts passiert keine
Hilfe wurde ausgegeben die Menschen
dürfen nicht einmal weg sie dürfen nicht
mal einmal evakuiert werden sondern sie
müssen da bleiben und die ukrainische
Armee hat das gesehen natürlich sie
sieht das mit drohen und hat jetzt die
einen sehr großen
oktocopter also ein nicht ein Quadcopter
mit vier Propellern sondern auch durch
Körper mit acht Propellern hingesteckt
vom Stück Vampire um dort Hilfsgüter
abzuwerfen hier fliegt er also wir sehen
jetzt noch mal den Weg da also Herr Zorn
statt ein städtisches Gebiet ein
bisschen höher gelegenes Gebiet wo es
wenig Überschwemmung gibt und hier sehen
wir diese kleinen Inselchen die im
südlich der Stadt sind in Niveau und
dort gibt es eine weitere Stadt und das
sehen wir uns mal an die hier jetzt
gerade angeflogen wurden wir sehen mal
wie katastrophal doch die Situation ist
wir haben also wirklich extrem viel
Überschwemmung wir haben kleine
Inselchen dass jemand gleich mal genauer
kleine Inselchen wo sich die Menschen
versucht haben drauf zu retten um ein
bisschen was trockenes zu haben und die
Situation sind also
Schönke heißt die Stadt hier da fliegt
gleich die Drohne hin diese Situation
dort ist wirklich katastrophal so wir
sehen also jetzt wie sich Menschen hier
auf eine Insel gerettet haben zusammen
mit einigen Kühen zusammen mit minimalen
Schlafmöglichkeiten und jetzt kommt
gleich die ukrainische Drohne und wirft
hier dieses Hilfsgüter ab da sehen wir
einen großen Sack der abgeworfen wird
und jetzt sehen wir noch mal wieder
ganze Sack da vorne ins Wasser fliegt
hier also der Sack und hier jetzt
Menschen hinkommen die das rausholen und
versuchen dort die Hilfsgüter
rauszuholen so das gelingt also erstmal
aber allein diese Lage ich meine man
muss sich das wirklich ansehen die Leute
leben hier wie in Flüchtlingslagern in
der Dritten Welt irgendwo im ja im
globalen Süden und hier sehen wir noch
mal wie dort die Situation ist also
komplette Überflutung kein Haus mehr
bewohnbar und hier eine kleine Insel wo
sich die Einwohner rauf gerettet haben
dann lass mal ganz kurz anhalten und wie
gesagt die Situation einfach mal zu
verstehen so hier also die Situation
sämtliche Häuser Gebäude auch die
Landwirtschaft die wir vielleicht hier
nördlich davon sehen und die wir hier
sehen alles ist vollkommen vernichtet
und die Einwohner haben sich auf eine
letzte kleine Insel mit ihren Kühen und
mit ein paar Plan gerettet und werden da
sehen sie noch mal von den Russen völlig
im Stich gelassen das ist Russisch
besetztes Gebiet Russland hatten halt
selbstverständlich als besatzungs die
Verantwortung für die Menschen dass sie
eben ja keine Not leiden aber wir sehen
wo es dann schätze ich nicht darum
sondern lässt die Ukrainer hier einfach
ja ihrem Schicksal über dass sie im
Schicksal und das sind die hilfskötter
die ausgepackt werden dass also vor
allem Wasser Trinkwasser natürlich das
Wichtigste für die Menschen die dort in
den letzten Gebieten leben und fast gar
nichts haben so also die Situation in
den Fluggebieten weiterhin katastrophal
und man muss ja auch sagen diese
flutgebiete das ist ja so kurzzeitige
Katastrophe dann im Laufe der Zeit oder
das Wasser natürlich wieder abfließen
das fehlende Wasser am See wird für
Millionen Ukraine sowohl in den freien
Gebieten als auch in den besetzten
Gebieten natürlich Langzeit zum großen
Problem denn dort wird immer mehr das
Trinkwasser knapp
[Musik]